[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm frances
foster
i'm constantine kitchen and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our terrific guest today is a
therapist and has been quite vocal on
the work stuff which is an important
part of the conversation
uh sir chaola welcome to trigonometry
thank you very much guys thanks for
having me uh listen it's so great to
have you you've been one of my absolute
favorite people to listen to and follow
on twitter over the last few weeks and
months
but before we get into some of your
views and how they've come to be formed
uh most of our followers won't know who
you are so tell everybody
uh who are you how are you where you are
what has been the journey that lead you
here because it's a very interesting one
isn't it
so i grew up in delhi um i'm six i come
from the sikh community and
um it was yeah
not not an easy place to grow up
necessarily there's a lot going on there
there's uh um
it's a patriarchal country and
i grew up during the rape crisis which
was really really difficult
and really frightening actually um it it
took a really long time even after i
came to the uk
to not be frightened all the time um
and not be frightened around men i'd say
that was a really big one
that is why we're doing this interview
remotely
[Laughter]
yes
excellent endorsement of that joke
perfect
uh so so you grew up in in this very uh
you know in a place where you fell in
danger you come over here
things uh you know you're trying to
adjust to a new world
uh and what was that like before we get
into into therapy and work stuff and
everything else
it was um on one hand i was i suppose
acclimatized because
um like during the 84 riots my parents
moved here because they were anti-sick
riots
my mom is culturally i'd say british
so i had that influence all the way
through growing up which i think made it
even harder
to be um in india because i had this
completely different cultural
understanding at home
and then the world around me was
much more um i'd say orthodox
patriarchal illiberal in some way in
many ways
um and coming to the uk felt like a
breath of fresh air but like you could
breathe again
go walk on the street um
every man you see is not danger to you
because it definitely can feel like that
sort of
navigating the world in india um
and it just i i think i felt like i ran
away to the uk
um so it sort of
i'd say my first few years but were very
much just
being here breathing again
and and just trying to get my bearings
more than
more than really accomplishing much i
used to um
i think my first job was ironing i used
to work for an events company in iron or
that was um and it was just just a it
was such a simple
sort of um you know you don't you don't
you can completely zone out as you stand
there when the steam coming into your
face
that's probably the hardest bit and just
um
do something really repetitive and um
and i think i was just trying to
regulate the world around me and just
get used to being somewhere safe
and sarah you you touched very uh
sort of lightly touched over the rape
crisis in india
for those people who are not aware of
that
what actually happened and what does
that mean
so it's i mean it's been named now in
the last
five to seven to ten years but it's
always been there
um and i think it's uh there's an
amalgam of factors
sex is very much taboo people aren't uh
you know you just you just don't talk
about it
it's sort of this dirty secret thing
you're dirty if you have sexual desire
so there's a lot of repression
and i think with such a sort of culture
of oppression
it's metastasized into this strange
perverse thing um it's like
people will grow even if you put them
into strange contorted shapes which is
what i feel
repression does but you grow in a warped
way and i think that's what's happened
and i think that combined with the way
women are seen as
um less than um
i wouldn't say maybe second class
citizens even
um and women are looked very much in
this sort of archetypal understanding of
mother maiden crone and you have a
service role
you're not necessarily an individual in
your own right
and a human being in the world you have
a
you have a function i think to perform
to be sexy to bear children
to be maternal to be a matriarch so i
think when you look at women
in that way and combine it with this
real sort of
perverse ideas around sex
the power imbalance and we've ended up
with this
pretty horrifying epidemic of um
you know even children aren't safe
children
are raped and abducted women are
gang-raped
and the new things now that they um
they burn them alive sometimes after
and i think the maybe the
not the most horrifying but the one that
got the most attention
was a few years ago um
a girl who's who was gang raped and they
disembowelled her
she it was just i remember seeing that
story it was tragic
um so you come from that
to to the uk and uh this is kind of
we're getting towards
the the main subject as opposed to the
conversation and you keep being told
that
in this country you live in a patriarchy
uh that's oppressive how does how does
that feel
um i think james lindsey has named it
really well by calling it a suit of
reality
that's how it feels um
i think i finally come to a place where
i very much trust my own possession
and for a long time i think well let me
try and understand how it's a patriarchy
here
and how how do women feel oppressed here
and then i think through
listening to this stuff and then finally
giving myself permission to think
actually i can say what i really think
this is not a [ __ ] patriarchy
it's not um and
women are yeah of course there's
violence against women
there's in every culture all over the
world there's also specific kinds of
violence against
men like gangs target men much more than
women because
you know so you can take any one fact
and spin a narrative around it can't you
um the point is that we should really
try to be tethered to reality
and we're not and i think this whole
idea about the west as a patriarchy
and is oppressive is what's not true
and you say it's not true and what has
been your experience when you have put
forward your point of view
and your own lived experience shall we
say
he's quoting scripture there it's really
really interesting because
at first it was like you're a woman of
color and you're almost
fetishized as if you have some secret
knowledge
that white people don't can't possibly
um
have access to and um you know sort of
white people shut the [ __ ] up and listen
to this woman of color
and then as soon as you go against their
dogma you're scapegoated
in in like they switch it's such a
strange
thing and it's interesting because it's
very close to what
um the pathology of gnosticism
where that you know they'll at first
perhaps put you on a pedestal
and say how wonderful you are and then
they'll
devalue you completely it's a feature of
a few personality disorders
um so yeah if you if you
go against the dogma and you don't tow
the party line
they will they will do what they can to
assassinate your character
and um there's even a white lady
in um i think she's in canada
who started insisting that i'm actually
secretly white
so yeah it's just absurd well the light
on your face does make you look quite
white at the moment so
maybe she's right but uh
you know the reason we were so curious
to have you
on is i think as a therapist you're
uniquely positioned because
um you know people can resist all this
critical social justice stuff on an
ideological level but
i think as someone who's who works with
people who works with mental health
uh one of the aspects that has been
massively underexplored i think of
teaching people this way of thinking is
that if you teach people
that they're victims you are actually
damaging
their mental health that's always been
my view and i haven't heard enough
people talk about it do you agree with
that
yes i do um i think the pendulum has
swung
far too far um and we're now
doing people a great disservice and
they're sort of
vast swathes of people that really
really believe
and the world is an awful place they're
traumatized
um that their immutable characteristics
limit them um and it's
it's really really unhealthy i think
coddling
and it's partly a type of coddling it's
sheltering people too much
it's treating instead of treating people
like autonomous adults we're treating
everybody
like they're a vulnerable adult you know
that's a very particular class of people
it's it's strange and not helpful it
feels like your if your mental health
was a muscle
it atrophies it's a very very
interesting way of putting it out of how
if your mental health is a muscle it
atrophies
because we do seem to want to cuddle
everybody now we talk in this language
like
microaggressions why do you think this
is so
particularly unhelpful this culture of
microaggressions
and i've got to be kept safe and i want
to be safe and words of violence etc etc
it's um i mean the genesis of it i'm
sure
you know people like james lindsey and
helen pluck rose
probably addressed in their book but the
mental health impacts i mean
this this sort of safetyism it's not
helpful
um coddling people and limiting
um you know sort of their experiences
because you're worried it's gonna damage
them somehow and you're conditioning
them to think that
um you know if i'm not wrapped in cotton
wool
something really awful is going to
happen to me i'm going to fall and fall
to peace these
it's the opposite of teaching people
resilience
it's the exact opposite of teaching
people resilience
and you're not the first person to say
that on that show i think when we had
linda
papadopoulos on the show she literally
said they're doing the opposite of what
we do in cbt
and so i suppose the question would be
you know as a therapist i imagine you
deal with people who
who've already got some kind of big
problem that they're trying to address
usually but what i don't think the
question really
often gets asked is what is actually a
healthy attitude
to challenge and to difficulty and to
disagreement
and to being uncomfortable and being
inconvenienced and being questioned and
like what would be a template for a
healthy behavior in
when you're faced with all of that stuff
so i do
agree when they say don't bypass your
feelings
i think that's there's some truth to
that and that's really important
um so if something difficult or
stressful happens
it's worth checking in with yourself and
not sort of glossing over it and putting
it away because
seeps out in some other way usually but
also
don't don't make it so big and magnify
it
that you um are sort of crushed under
the weight of it
you know like we we need to teach people
some sorts of
um like strategies around stress
management
and when something difficult happens
that how to mentalize that that doesn't
mean because this difficult thing
happened to me today
the rest of my life is going to be
marred by this and i'm going to fall
into a depression
sort of like this isn't forever this
hurts but it's going to pass
it will be okay um sort of
leaning into your own sense of
competence and your own inner resources
your sense of resilience and
having a sense of trust that you can you
will be okay
and you've dealt with much you know with
difficult things before and just like
that you'll deal with this
it's sort of challenging these limiting
thoughts
that we which is what most of this um
safetyism is
it's limiting thoughts on a mass scale
and
um it's challenging them it's talking
yourself through them it's using reason
um while looking after yourself and not
not making it this um your mental health
and your feelings the sort of apex
enterprise of your life
because other things are more important
you know you have to look past the end
of your nose
and we're teaching people the exact
opposite of that they're just
navel gaze all day long and nothing else
is
particularly important and sir do you
think in a way now
we've talked to we've used the word or
fetishizing once do you think we've
started to fetishize mental health
like people start to see being a
depressive or
having borderline personality disorder
it's not only a disorder anymore
it's now become an identity people put
in their twitter bios
yeah mental health has been fetishized
in the really
i don't want to use the word disgusting
and probably say the word
worrying way um
and it's become yet another you know in
the intersectionalities
of i'm brown and i'm a woman and i'm
this and i'm that and i have
self-diagnosed autism and i've got
something else and i've got borderline
and
on and on and again it's making these
immutable characteristics these sort of
central axes of your
identity and of your being rather than
you know it's so limiting it's shoving
yourself in a grubby little box
and saying this is all i am and
in being just just these small things my
color my race
my gender and whatever
that's really important and everybody
else must see it is really important
it's a very unrealistic and
inappropriate way to approach your
identity as opposed to what you love
what books do you read
what makes your heart sing what are you
passionate about
why are those not more important
questions about identity
that's a really good point i suppose we
all focus on the negative at the moment
so much
and there is quite a lot of negatives to
be focused on at the moment which
as a pessimist is [ __ ] brilliant yeah
uh
but but actually i mean as a therapist i
would imagine
that making from your point of view i
would imagine that making
some kind of mental health issue
or problem or whatever diagnosis part of
your identity would be
would make it essentially impossible to
ever recover from that
because you've bought into the identity
so much well is that fair to say or am i
exaggerating
i think it's a double-edged sword
because there are people who are quite
unwell
and will have lifelong you know um
struggles with mental health they're
people whose lives are sort of
crossed by the shadow of depression um
and other illnesses and for them
it is something that informs who they
are
but that's not what's being done
publicly or in this sort of
um in what you described that's sort of
glamorizing and fetishizing
a disorder that you might or might not
have because you've they've often
self-diagnosed
um and and
just talking about that constantly again
what you put you what you all
the stuff you focus all your attention
on which is that the world is an
awful place um there's white
supremacists around every corner waiting
to murder everybody
um you know the the
west is a patriarchy i'm oppressed
um people don't care about my mental
illness this
very pseudo realistic understandings
because
you know people don't stop talking about
mental illness there's
there's so many even the royals are
talking about the importance of mental
health
talking of like a stuffy institution
they're talking about it
it's there's constant campaigns it's
it's very much mainstream it's very well
understood
but they're they're behaving like
none of that exists it's really peculiar
they do they are it's a great point they
do behave like none of that exists what
do you think that is
i don't know whether it's um an echo
chamber thing
i don't know whether it's um i think
there's a lot of there are a lot of
people who get really really
um a big payoff out of being part of a
group
that's against something because again
they're not
they're not necessarily building
anything they're not um
creating you know they're not coming up
with strategies or solutions
they're not um helping people up
they're tearing things down and there's
a real you know even with the some of
the footage of the riots
there's a real chilling sort of sense
that people are having a really good
time doing this
they're singing they're skipping around
they're smashing things there's like
a pleasure from the sense of destruction
oh i totally get that i
i'm a mistrupp i hate people but i i
would totally
i mean i can totally see how much fun it
would be
to be in a group of other people with a
common purpose
uh just smashing something up what a
great way to spend your day
it was brilliant it is i i can totally
relate to it which is
where you need sort of to play to
people's better angels
and encourage them to be involved in in
even in movements for change if you
believe that there's injustice or
whatever
but that are constructive but that that
doesn't that doesn't seem to be
what's happening um but you know from
your point
as as someone who works with people and
helps to improve
their mental health what do you think
would be a healthy societal approach to
talking about these issues and having
these conversations because as francis
says
you know we seem to talk about all the
time now yeah
i think it's fair to say that if you
were to measure people's sense of
well-being over the last 50 60 70 years
i think all the data shows that we're
getting more miserable aren't we
we're getting more miserable and there's
so many reasons for that um
we're not you know we sit inside all day
i mean the last year has been pretty
devastating for that
sit inside all day and you stare at
screens um
most of us aren't moving we're not
eating things that would nourish our
body and make us feel better
and um you know movement is
really when we live incredibly sedentary
lives if you look at history we
even if you exercise for an hour or even
two day that's still
kind of nothing compared to um how we
were living
all those things have an impact because
the
you know the world around us might have
changed our wiring hasn't
we're still we're sort of a primitive
thing in this
strange changing world and i think that
gap is ever widening
and we're not learning how to deal with
that gap very well
um and we're suffering because of it and
it's doing really funny things to
people's minds
so even with the last year and and the
pressure people have been under not just
being stuck indoors all day
which being stuck inside for pretty much
an entire year
is gonna have a pretty profound impact
on your
you know sense of feeling
good in the world and good in yourself
but
even some of the conspiracy theories
that have come out of the last year
or um some of the sort of analyses
people
are putting out about this capital um
you know this attack that's just
happened it's
how are you making these connections
this has absolutely you know looking at
the
the footage of these people they're a
bunch of clowns
there's a bunch of idiots who've gotten
who've broken into this building
but to then call it a targeted
insurrection or coup
sort of like how are you spinning this
why are we not looking at reality
naming it very clearly and staying
tethered to it
instead of spinning these narratives and
everyone is confused the media has
not just the media social media everyone
is getting into your head and confusing
you further
um and then you know we've removed the
meta narratives people don't have
um a sense of community and meaning
based on anything else
and then they lean into stuff like
wokeness or on the other end of the
spectrum q anon you know just wacky
ideas
that are not based in reality francis
did you know that
investing is one of the best ways to
preserve your wealth over the long term
what's well something you will never
find out as long as i have control of
the trigonometry account
however if you do have wealth high
commission and clunky products
from traditional stock brokers make it
very difficult for people like me
to start investing good for everyone
else though
free trade has come up with an
award-winning app that is currently
being used by over 250
000 people it's fca approved and fscs
protected it's brilliant it allows you
to trade commission free
free trade has won best online trading
platform at the british bank awards
two years in a row 2019 and 2020.
they offer no speculative products no
spread betting no day trading
it's all about preserving and growing
your wealth over long term
no hidden fees transparent price and
structure very simple to use
you can sign up for a general investment
account or a stocks and shares
isa or sign up to free trade plus for
more advanced order types and a bigger
stock universe
they've also got other new products
coming soon you can get a universe
go to free trade dot io trigger
register and fund your account and
you'll get a randomly allocated free
share
worth between three and two hundred
pounds could be in a great company like
right move apple even greg's great so
when you invest your capital is at risk
the value of your investments can go up
as well as down and you may receive back
less than you originally invested you
knew that bit off by heart
and we talk about not being based in
reality and we talk about the impact
that the previous year has had isn't the
problem sir
or a large part of it is social media
and now we're spending hours and hours
on our phone
and essentially having our brains hacked
by these social media companies
whose only vested interest is keeping us
on our phones on our laptops for over
longer periods of time
follow us on twitter at trigger pod
absolutely and all the social media
platforms
for unvarnished truth absolute
abso-fucking-lutely and at the same time
how how'd you get off them i'm as
addicted as anybody else
i go to wee and i'm looking on twitter
like it's just you can't stop
it's like the it's almost like the phone
is handcuffed to your
wrist and and that's how it feels
it it weirdly um
it's like the phone is an extension of
your mind
and when you leave your phones none of
us would
would um not understand the
the kind of discomfort you feel if you
leave your phone at home by accident
we all know that it's like you're
suffering till you get it back
this is this is not normal and we're so
attached to this device
yeah well i mean that is what makes it
so empowering too right like
we are tapping in literally with our
brains into this big
network of into the cloud and that's
what makes it so powerful
on the other hand it's also what makes
it so powerful as in terms of having an
impact on our brain
yeah so we i think we've got to the
diagnosis very well sir you've talked
about all the reasons that we
are as messed up as we are what sort of
advice do you
would you give people or do you give
people particularly now where
certainly in the uk we're all stuck
indoors in other countries it's you know
they've got different rules
what are some of the healthy things you
can do
to protect your body and mind from both
you know the impact of lockdown but also
the bombardment of social media and all
this other stuff
i think we have to really there's
social media elicits a lot of really big
emotional stuff
it's really easy to get high on hate
it's really easy to get self-righteous
it's really easy to go online
and just sort of fire off all these
horrible impulses that you're carrying
around
because you're not feeling very happy
because life is difficult
and you have that's a muscle that you
have to build you have to practice not
doing that
you know if someone comes to your um
i i mean it's a difficult line to walk
and i don't want to be a hypocrite here
because if someone comes and is really
really rude i won't take it
and i don't suffer fools gladly but at
the same time
um there's also lines that i won't cross
and i think you have to figure out what
that is for you
um and you know i know we're allowed to
go out and exercise
and all that stuff in the uk with the
lockdowns
but i think there's a lot of people are
even struggling to access that at the
moment
i think there's not just the sort of
adjustment disorder sort of depression
let's say from
the pandemic and all that stress because
then we have a lot less sunlight at the
moment this is typically the time most
people are slightly lower in
mood so just look after yourself
you know don't don't engage with
horrible stuff
guard your mind because that's that's
the most important thing
don't feed your mind horrible miserable
toxic things
unplug from from some of that stuff and
really
um there's there's this term
in um one of the trauma therapies so you
know what a trigger is something that
that um of course you know what the
trigger is
yeah i think i think we know what a
trigger is
but in in trauma terms a trigger isn't
necessarily the
internet form of being triggered but
like an actual trigger where
you're involuntarily um immersed in in
something
you know something that reminds you of
your trauma and
it's sort of quite a horrible thing so a
glimmer
is the exact opposite of that it's
something that involuntarily
puts you in a really good state so
imagine when you listen to
a song that you just [ __ ] love and
you haven't heard in a while and then it
kind of makes your heart sing
and you feel it in your body that's a
glimmer
so you know you have to incorporate more
things like that into your life you'd be
really intentional about it
because the shitty stuff is a deluge
that you can't stop
you know that damn has been broken so
you have to build like a cent a wall
around yourself
and all of these sorts of practices are
what look after you
and don't be scared of discomfort and
adversity that's what makes you grow
don't you know do difficult things prove
to yourself
that you have a sense of competence that
you're strong that you're capable
you can go through hard things and
survive them um
you know if i had it my way i would
completely get rid of safety culture
because i think it's making people
unwell
um but as we can't do that i guess we do
what we can
with what we have and i think that's a
good attitude to take into life as well
which is
um don't be defeatist do what you can
with what you have
and you'll be surprised at how much more
you have than you really think
have you ever been abroad and felt out
of place because you didn't speak the
language
no because i voted brexit brexit means
brexit
i know that sometimes you're abroad you
don't speak the local language it's very
awkward like france is talking to a
woman
so you have to shout do you want to
learn another language
i don't for obvious reasons but if you
do
babel is quite simply one of the finest
language learning apps in the business
babel offers a clear and easy to use
interface they have daily 10 to 15
minute lessons
that have been proven effective across
many studies
showing that you can learn up to 14
languages that they offer
so it doesn't matter if you struggle
with language maybe you find it
difficult to pick up or maybe you're
just
english right now babel is offering our
fans
six months free on a six-month
subscription with babel
using our special code which is of
course trigger
that's babble b a b b
e l dot co dot uk
slash play and use the promo code
trigger look at that spelling he learned
english on babel
i did but seriously go to babel dot co
dot uk forward slash play use our code
trigger
and enjoy babel and do you think part of
the problem as well is that
and again this goes back to social media
we're in a constant state of feeling
that actually
we're being denied that people are doing
better than us we've lost our ability to
be grateful
i don't feel that way i'm crushing it
and not just lost our ability to be
grateful
there's active messaging saying you're
under no obligation to be grateful
that's toxic positivity
you don't have to find gratitude yeah
i didn't i haven't heard that one is
that is that a thing yeah that's the
thing
what so what's toxic positivity there's
some truth in it
which is that you know there's a lot of
like woo-woo spiritual type of people
who
you know um i'm in a different reality
and
racism is you know lower vibration
rubbish
it's just you know silly people saying
silly things and it's evolved into
um this idea that even when
say you're mentally ill or you've had
trauma or something
you just try and feel positive and be
grateful
oh that doesn't work you have to deal
with the issue yeah right so that's what
but that toxic positivity has now
has always been taken too far and now
the
there's a real rhetoric amongst so i'm
in the insta
instagram therapy niche and every day
i'll see two or three posts
you don't have to find a lesson in your
trauma you don't have to
um of course you don't but maybe you
should try
and maybe you should think about things
why limit yourself before
um you know you don't have to feel
gratitude
if you're not feeling uh christmas cheer
that's completely fine
cons it's this constant you know what
they think is
this validating affirming stuff but it's
subliminally
messaging the subliminal messaging to
people is
um positivity is not aspirational
uh people who are successful people who
are functional
people who make something of themselves
and build themselves up
that's now a privileged villain and
the the virtue and the good stuff comes
from people who are sitting and hurting
and there's a lot of the subliminal
messaging that's i think
really um damaging and worrying and
a horrible idea and sir if the people
come in with this particular mindset and
they're already
thinking like this thinking this
particular vic
have it constructed themselves as victim
narrative doesn't it make it incredibly
difficult for
you to treat them very very difficult
they're the hardest people to work with
um you know in private practice anyway
because you don't take on necessarily
people who are very seriously unwell
wouldn't be appropriate in this setting
but yes
it's very very very difficult and
um it's because they have a real
investment
in in staying as they are because they
get a social reward from it their
in-group rewards them constantly
they get social status from it they get
attention
um they've now they've constructed an
identity
around being a person who was hard done
by
suffering not okay and i think there's a
real sense of fear around
being okay being successful and being
functional because for one you're going
to get kicked out of your
your social group if you do and i think
we
we don't kind of think about that that's
a big thing
especially if you're young in your late
teens and early 20s that's a massive
loss
um so i i have a few clients
like that and all of them have said some
version
of i'm scared to be well and scared to
be better
that doesn't surprise me at all i think
the group instinct and group status and
approval is such a big thing
it's quite similar in substance abuse
isn't it like someone who wants
to stop taking certain substances or
drinking alcohol with friends or
whatever
they will often have to let go of that
group and that can be quite a big
obstacle uh but let's let's talk about
you a little bit because
you know you're a therapist you're in
private practice i would not have
thought that
coming out publicly and having strong
views on the cultural issues would
necessarily be
uh you know the most helpful thing for
you from a sort of business point of
view
why have you chosen to to be as vocal as
you are
about these issues it felt irresponsible
not
to and why is that because it feels like
well for one i think it's ruining my
field
i think um now we we have much less
actual psychotherapists
um that are doing actual psychotherapy
as opposed to
either guidance counselors who want to
validate everyone for everything
or activists who are just labeled
therapists
it's like all the grievance study
scholars they are
um all activists with different labels
one is a teacher one is a scholar one's
a social worker one's
a therapist but their primary function
is is activism and that can't it just
can't
infiltrate therapy it's sort of against
um any form of proper work
and it's it's sort of also against
most of my personal the things i believe
in i believe in stoicism
and um in in
not being a defeatist and being you know
striving and moving forward and um
doing difficult things and not blaming
everybody else
and taking responsibility for the stuff
you can control
and it's the pretty much polar opposite
messaging it's being given to people and
being called therapeutic
no i was going to say it seems to me
that what they're doing and correct me
if i'm wrong is politicizing therapy
which
it's it's it's just insane can you
explain why
politics and and therapy and therapy
should be
i can't believe i'm asking this question
but it needs to be asked why should they
be completely separate
well it's like saying well why should
spaghetti and spaceships be separate
well there should have never been it's
just two things that have nothing to do
with each other
there shouldn't have been to get it's
just absolutely so angry about this
and you have these these people talking
about how
the personal is political well if you
question them you scratch
you know on the veneer a little bit well
there's nothing under there they have no
responses for that what that really
means
therapy is political uh why because
you know there's white supremacy and and
patriarchy and all these different
oppressions
and therapists um you know it impacts
clients so therapists have to be really
involved and advocate for this
it's like well you're not a fireman and
you're not a social worker
and you're not a police but you know
you're a therapist
do your actual job and let other people
do their jobs
and the point of therapy is that you
provide somebody
a safe unbiased
container in which that you know they
can start to
become who they are deal with their
stuff
like make quite deep in-depth
exploration of really difficult things
you don't need biases and the therapies
that i mean that's completely contrary
to anything
that would would create useful therapy
the therapist bias the therapist
politics the therapists lived experience
all of why is the therapist all of a
sudden
this um why are they the star of the
therapy
they shouldn't be it should always be
about the client
and i suppose one thing we haven't
actually asked you about is
what is the therapy industry or the
field
like at the moment um so i've been in
private practice for a little while so
i'm not necessarily
around a lot of therapists all the time
but
based on the instagram niche which is
you've got hundreds of therapists in it
it's increasingly
woke even therapists in this country
you know the some of the ones that i
know they um
i think people just go along with it
they're told this is the right thing
this is the pc
thing you just have to go along with it
and it's a slow creep you know it's like
boiling a frog
and slowly before you know it you're
talking about um
you're lecturing your white clients on
their privilege in the session
[Laughter]
is this interview a guy comes in and
says i'm depressed and you go that's
because you're a white man
yeah that's great the first bit is
they're paying for it
that'll be 50 quid thank you very much
it's
awesome and i mean this obviously you've
talked about the
boiling frog metaphor this didn't
obviously happen overnight
but how long has this been coming i mean
i think this has been coming for a
really long time
but the infiltration into therapy seems
to be a more
you know i'm not sure
but for me i've seen it in the last
couple of years
and where it's become really prominent
and really difficult to ignore
and i started being quite vocal about it
because it got to the point where i
thought you're gonna
you're not doing therapy you're not
helping people you're doing something
really um
unethical and awful and calling it good
um and i couldn't be quiet about that
it felt really strongly about it um
it's you know you have therapists
constantly talking about their own
privilege
um you have a lot of infighting you know
the therapist behaving like um
crabs in a bucket over
just this hierarchy of i'm the most
woke i'm the most anti-oppressive
um i'm the least privileged look at my
you know
35 different intersectionalities it's
just become
this weird narcissistic performance and
again it just has nothing to do with
therapy
has nothing to do with the psyche and
helping people it's a good example
though of what their psyche
or a good illustration of what their
psyche might be like
um beyond that no not really and isn't
this just an example
of society becoming more and more
narcissistic
yeah that's all we're doing aren't we
just focusing on ourselves
yeah it's great it's great
and it's also a nightmare and it's
you know just this navel gazing like
what has happened to everybody
um i don't know maybe i'm really
old-fashioned in this way and maybe i've
got it wrong
but i think sitting around thinking
about your feelings all day
is just a horrendous idea
and you're going to make yourself upset
you're not going to be a good
partner employee parent any of those
things
um and
i just i don't yeah i know words
sometimes
uh evade all of us on this issue uh but
let me ask you about this you mentioned
intersections
and here you are a pseudo-brown uh
foreign-born uh woman yeah oppressed in
every way
uh religious minority you know all the
rest of it
woman spoke with an ex of course
obviously yeah
yeah as we call it on trigonometry
so uh do you do you have any sympathy
for the idea that you know if you if you
come from
a mixture of these groups that are not
traditionally speaking advantaged in
society that that you are
more disadvantaged than others but
automatically do you have any
uh sympathy with that or do you just
think uh that that's wrong
i think all these ideas have a kind of
truth to them
yeah but they're misapplied like
intersectionality
um isn't it supposed to be for to make
sure the legal system doesn't
miss out ways in which people are
discriminated against
or how to make sure you're you're
deploying
proper resources and not missing
anything out
by looking at all the different
intersections of ways in which
you know you're i don't like using this
word but oppressed
um but it's it's not it's not applied
that way
anymore now it's sort of like a blue
head university student
who has you know got 30 different things
and
and 50 different emojis in their bio
about how oppressed they are
while they skateboat actual people of
color online
this is it's really been my my
experience since i've been speaking
about this
i find um a lot of woke white people
will you they talk about
don't use your don't weaponize your
identity
as a p as a person of color or whatever
so they use this this term don't
weaponize your identity
but then they use theirs at every
available opportunity
um and they use it to basically hammer
out descent
so intersectionality is yet another
thing to use their term
that's been weaponized and been used as
an as a
exercise in narcissism instead of being
applied for what it was which was a tool
not a weapon and sarah why do you think
it is that more people
especially people in the field of mental
health can see what what is happening
can see that these
practices and behaviors are deeply
unhealthy unhelpful and unhealthy
why is it that more people haven't stood
up and said this
is lunacy it's i mean i'm at a loss for
that as well i don't understand
how you can be exposed for this to this
for a while and not start to say hang on
this isn't right something's something's
really wrong here
um and there's very few people
i mean i could probably think of 300
therapists in that instagram niche
and maybe three of us talk about it
so it's really odd there's a few
therapists on twitter that talk about it
um i don't know i don't know whether
it's to do with
personality traits and it's that kind of
agreeableness
needing to be needed being cooperative
staying in the group
i think a lot of therapists have that
trait that need to be needed
um which again you know sort of
indicates other traits of
needing to um be accepted and be in the
group and
i don't know whether that that is a part
of it i don't know whether it's because
um you know universities are
indoctrinating people into this theory
and
and they're coming out into the world
with this um
preconceived blueprint and they
superimpose it onto the world
and then demand that everybody else sees
you know looks through their
their rose tinted glasses whatever or
maybe not rose tinted whatever the
opposite of that is
um i don't know i i'm really confused
about that myself
like these are people who are supposed
to understand human behavior
and people who are supposed to um you
think have quite good ethics
and they're watching people cancel each
other they're getting involved in it
um they're doing just weird anti-social
horrible things
and i'm very confused by it i think the
whole world is very confused by it but
uh we we haven't really talked about
politics and we don't need to get too
much into it but i just wanted to ask
do you think uh now that the you know
the evil orange man
has left the building uh people will
calm down a bit do you think a lot of
this was
a sort of visceral response to you know
donald trump was a divisive figure
uh the way he spoke made people very
uncomfortable though the way
uh he didn't play by certain traditional
rules when it came to being president or
being a candidate
it made people uneasy like
you know you want most people want the
leader of the of the free world
so-called
to be this grounding stable figure who
can always be relied on to
to deliver calm and a sort of measured
tone
donald trump you know whether you like
him or not was not that i think everyone
who's rational would agree on that
do you think that now that now that he's
no longer going to be president
people will sort of feel like all right
we don't need to fight so hard we can
relax a little bit we can
we can ease off uh or am i just being
very uh toxically positive about this
i don't know it's it's hard i mean
because it's a group of people that
have have sort of built their identities
and their life purpose
about railing against something whether
it's there or not
you know donald trump definitely um
gave them something someone to hate and
he gave them someone to you know
complain about
but i think
they might settle down slightly but they
are also going to get a lot of
institutional power behind them
so i don't know i think it's going to be
a really um
i think we should watch with caution
yeah well i hear you i mean i was saying
to the boys here at the studio this
morning like
what is cnn going to talk about now you
know
what what are all these woke people
gonna do and
it sounds like what you're really saying
is they've banded together around an
identity and they're gonna have to
direct the energy somewhere
and now now they're gonna be in power
and now they're controlling all the big
tech um
yeah uh 2021 is going to be a great year
started out well isn't it
[Laughter]
gone no i was just no i was just so yeah
it
it really didn't start out very very
well is there any optimism for the
future surat
there's always optimism i think you have
to hold on to that don't you
um yes i think there is and i think
the optimism is that more and more
people perhaps
therapists but everyone else are kind of
kind of you know waking up to this and
people are getting fed up of it and
luckily not everyone is is
a reactive um or you know not everyone
wants to be a counter force
there are a lot of people are waking up
to this and saying actually this isn't
okay
i'm not going to be involved in it i'm
not going to bend a knee
and i'm also not going to bully you back
like i'm not having this like strong
straight-spined people that are standing
up for this and i think
that's something to be really optimistic
about it is and you talk about these you
know the people standing up to
i think a lot of people now are in a
quandary because
people like us are coming out and
talking and saying this is unacceptable
whatever it may be but you get people
who for
one reason or another are uncomfortable
but don't feel that they
can speak up what would your advice be
to people like them
who maybe aren't as inclined or don't
have the personality types
to confront these bullies well even if
you don't want to speak up about it you
don't have to
encourage it go along with it um
and i think what i'd recommend to those
people is to do what i did
which is to set up something like a
twitter account
you don't have to say anything you start
listening to people
and see what's being said and you know
start to
i pro i tweeted because that one of the
things that i get out of tweeting is
working out my own ideas
and then you get instant feedback and
it's one way to figure out what how you
feel about
things but you can also do that just by
listening to people not not inflammatory
you know nightmare people but listen to
reasoned
rational people and and a variety of
voices don't be in an echo chamber i
think people that are stuck
in that woke echo chamber wherever it is
um they think everyone thinks like that
and they're terrified
of having that angry mob turn on them as
soon as you leave it you realize there a
tiny little very loud
minority and there's a lot this big
world
it's full of a lot of different people
and it's
it's okay you'll be okay listen to what
other people are saying as well
widen your focus would be my advice
it's good advice sir and listen it's
been great chatting to you i i think one
of the
reasons we wanted to speak with you is
that uh there are so many fields that
are being affected in this way and
you know whether it's comedy whether
it's therapy whether it's journalism
whether it's
sport you know all acting all of these
all of these fields and we're gonna
as the year goes on to speak to more and
more people from these different
different fields
uh but uh as you know uh when we finish
the show we always
uh finish with the same question which
is what is the one thing that no one is
talking about that we really should be
i think we should be talking about
not reacting to things we should be
talking about
grounding yourself and finding a center
we're talking about how your hot take
isn't needed in the world
it's much more important
to look after yourself you know we need
to we need to start having conversations
around
um calming the [ __ ] down
that everyone has no chill and um
just work on yourself grow those muscles
modulate your behavior regulate your
emotions
stop just reacting to things stop um
you know you see someone broke into the
capital so you
you decide that's white supremacy when
you don't have all the facts
so without the facts you don't you don't
have an accurate assessment
so you start thinking like that we need
more reason
we need you know um people to be more
circumspect and to start building
bridges because everyone on the left
isn't woke
and um everyone on the right has been
sadly tired
as a bigot and we need to we need to
stop
all of that all that division and find
a way to actually see each other as
human beings
and be okay with the fact that people
who are not you
will have thoughts that you wouldn't
have and that's not something to flip
out about
if it's not a thought in your head it's
not your business
let other people think what they like
you know just
get calm yeah i'm sure that will
definitely happen this year
sarah thank you so much for your time
it's been a pleasure i
i really as i said at the very top of
the interview you're one of my
twitter faves at the moment uh where can
people find you online
so i'm on twitter at searetkowler
and same handle on instagram and maybe
you can put that in your caption
somewhere because you know we absolutely
will and
equally there may be people who who want
to uh get your help
in terms of therapy what's the best way
for them to to find you for that
at the moment i'm not taking on too many
people but um i'm building a website
which will be up soon which will also be
syracha vlog
so that's being built and it will yeah
all right perfect thank you so much for
coming on and thank you guys for
watching
we will see you very soon with another
episode or a live stream
and they always go out 7pm uk time take
care guys and see you soon